Speaker 1: So while I was away, we had this,
I mean, it's I know people laugh at me when
I say it, but it's the right word.
We had this Kafka esque moment where during
another one of these half sold out public
events with Donald Trump and disgraced former
Fox News host Bill O'Reilly, Donald Trump
said Vaccines are good and I got the booster
and the crowd started booing him, and Dr.
Anthony Fauci was on CNN over the weekend
and he was asked, What did you make of that?
And basically, Dr. Fauci couldn't believe
how stupid Trump supporters who booed are.
Now that's my characterization.
To be clear, Dr. Fauci's words were were a
little softer.
He said he was dismayed.
And he was stunned.
Now, at this point, being stunned by what
Trump supporters do, we're kind of long past
being stunned.
We're going to look at that clip in a moment.
But as a reminder, here's the moment from
the Trump Bill O'Reilly event at which Trump
and O'Reilly say We've gotten the booster
and the crowd boos, and Trump tries to calm
them down.
Speaker 4: But look, we did something that
was historic.
We saved tens of millions of lives worldwide.
We together, all of us.
Not me.
We we got a vaccine done.
Three vaccines done and tremendous therapeutics
like Regeneron and other things that have
saved a lot of lives.
We got a vaccine done in less than nine months
that we're supposed to take from five to 12
years because of that vaccine, because of
that vaccine.
Millions and millions of people.
I think this would have been the Spanish flu
of 1917, where up to a hundred million people
died.
This was going to ravage the country far beyond
what it is right now.
Take credit for it.
Take credit for it's a great what we've done
is historic.
Don't let them take away.
Don't take it away from ourselves.
You're playing that.
You're playing right into their hands when
you sort of like, Oh, the vaccine, if you
don't want to take it, you shouldn't be forced
to take it.
No mandates.
But take credit because we saved tens of millions
of lives.
Take credit.
Don't let them take that away from you.
OK, so the president made.
Do you agree with that right?
Both the president and I are vaccinated.
Do you get the booster?
Yes, I got it too.
OK, so on da da da da da DA Nang, and that's
always a very tiny group of OK.
Speaker 1: So there it is Trump vaccine, Trump
boosted.
It's an accomplishment.
It's great.
And the crowd is booing fine.
So Fauci also in this clip that we're going
to look at was asked about the Candace Owens
Trump interview, which we looked at earlier
in the show, in which she does the anti-vax
stuff.
And Trump goes, No, the vaccines are good.
So I played that clip earlier, but just as
a reminder, so we have it all in this clip.
Here is that clip again, which Dr. Fauci was
asked about and will react to.
Speaker 3: We see the corruption right.
It doesn't seem like anybody ever pays for
the corruption.
And right now, we're seeing corruption life.
Even in terms of big pharma, which is a huge
topic on the minds of mothers, especially,
you're seeing what's happening at these school
board meetings.
Where do you stand on these vaccine mandates?
And obviously, I know that you are your pro
vaccine obviously did everything you could
to get this vaccine out.
I know it was one
Speaker 4: of the greatest achievements we
did in the nine
Speaker 3: months to be able to do that.
But now it's taken a twist, right?
It's it's gotten.
Now we went from this is a good thing and
people should have this option to military
men.
You're going to have to resign because you're
not getting this vaccine.
Where do you stand on that?
Speaker 4: Well, I stand on forget about the
mandates that people have to have their freedom.
But at the same time, the vaccine is one of
the greatest achievements of mankind.
We would have had in 1917.
Remember the Spanish flu killed perhaps a
hundred million people?
Actually, it ended the First World War because
the soldiers was a lot of people don't know
that the soldiers got so sick.
It was a terrible thing.
There was no vaccines.
It would know anything.
I came up with a vaccine with three vaccines.
All are very, very good.
Came up with three of them in less than nine
months.
It was supposed to take five to 12 years,
and
Speaker 3: we say people have died under COVID
this year.
By the way, under Joe Biden, then under you
and more people took the vaccine this year.
So people are questioning how
Speaker 4: the vaccine work.
But some people aren't the ones.
The ones who get very sick and go to the hospital
are the ones that don't take the vaccine.
But it's still their choice.
And if you take the vaccine, you're protected.
Look, the results of the vaccine are very
good, and if you do get it, it's a very minor
form.
People aren't dying when they take the vaccine,
but
Speaker 3: the masking of children.
Speaker 1: OK, so those are the that's the
material.
Those are the two clips that Dr. Fauci is
asked about, and he was asked about it yesterday
on ABC.
So check out what Dr. Fauci had to say.
Speaker 4: You know, it was interesting on
this question of vaccination.
I'm sure you saw President Trump.
Former President Trump, I said, came out and
said that he had received the booster shot.
He actually got booed a little bit by the
crowd of support of his supporters, as he
said that.
And now, you know, there's another interview
he just did with a conservative outlet with
Candace Owens, where he really pushed back
on the idea that the vaccine is not protecting
people.
He said that the people going to hospitals
are are the ones largely that haven't been
vaccinated.
You don't die if you get the vaccine that
does Donald Trump's words.
I mean, it'll be interesting to see if his
supporters listen to that.
Well, I certainly hope so, John.
We'll take anything we can get about getting
people vaccinated.
I was a bit dismayed when former President
Trump came out and made that statement and
his followers booed him, which I was stunned
by that.
I mean, given the fact of how popular he is
with that group that they would boo him, which
tells me how recalcitrant they are about being
told what they should do.
And I think that his continuing to say that
people should get vaccinated and articulating
that to them in my mind is a good thing.
I hope he keeps it up.
Yeah, let's hope he says it loudly now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Trump telling people to get
vaccinated is basically a win win unless you
want Republicans to die.
And I know some of you do, but that's not
my that's not my thing.
OK, so I'll explain.
Some of Trump's followers are going to hear
Trump say this stuff and they will actually
go and get vaccinated.
And as